yeah there is a great vegan chef I mean
there were a few at this point and um
yeah I think that it's you know actually
this is an interesting story
I met a vegan chef from Japan a couple
of years ago
tiny tiny woman really interesting and
uh and not a vegan in her personal life
but she was the vegan chef she ran it
small maybe twelve or twenty seat
restaurant in Tokyo and everything was
strictly vegan and when I found that she
wasn't a vegan I said I don't get this I
mean why would you choose to it's not a
matter of principle for you because you
eat meat you eat fish why would you
choose to narrow what you serve your
customers when you yourself eat from the
broadest spectrum possible and she said
it's like pen and ink there are people
who choose to be artists in only pen and
ink because they want to narrow the
world in which they're looking at so is
to more fully explore it and I want to
narrow the world in which I'm cooking so
I can understand it better and she was
an amazing amazing chef she made great
great stuff
I you know I I'd be guessing to answer
that question and um it's a confluence
of a bunch of things I mean first off I
guess is that we we like fads I mean we
like trends so here's one that hadn't
been fully exploited secondly food
television really had it has had a huge
impact I mean cooking and eating as a
spectator sport never before in history
so that's had a huge impact third I
think is the kind of
internationalization of food people not
only people traveling and seeing food
from the rest of the world but
ingredients and types of cuisines and
restaurants arriving here in
unprecedented numbers so I think you
know I guess the short answer is
exposure but it still doesn't explain
doesn't explain you know walking into a
party and having someone come up to you
and say I'm a foodie and there's
something about this sort of trendiness
it's like saying you know I'm a clothes
person well yeah we all wear clothes I'm
a clothes person too the thing that
makes me most upset about this big fed
is that more people are not cooking and
that I think it's fine to watch other
people cook but then people say well I'm
too busy to cook and they're too busy to
cook because they're watching people
cook on television it doesn't track for
me I think it's really really bad